in a very strange turn of events Donald
Trump is now slamming Republican Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell on
Twitter
not that McConnell doesn't deserve a
good thumping here and there believe me
he does but to see Donald Trump attack
not only a Republican leader but one of
the Republicans who might depending on
where the Trump Russia investigation
goes actually could decide the fate of
Donald Trump's presidency sort of weird
Donald Trump took to Twitter and said
senator Mitch McConnell said I had
excessive expectations but I don't think
so after seven years of hearing repeal
and replace why not done so what
triggered this for Trump Mitch McConnell
recently said that Donald Trump of
course we have Mitch McConnell was asked
in Kentucky at some kind of constituent
event
why hasn't more been achieved by the
Trump administration and Mitch McConnell
said something pretty reasonable which
is our new president has not been in
this line of work before I think he had
excessive expectations about how quickly
things happen in the democratic process
that's a pretty reasonable explanation
like Trump made all sorts of promises if
they were legitimate honest promises
it's very likely he underestimated the
difficulty of actually legislating in
the United States House and Senate it's
absolutely a reasonable and effective
attack you just don't expect it to come
from a fellow Republican I think that's
why this is a big story i I think that
Donald Trump is as I've said before a
sort of clueless buffoon with delusions
of grandeur suffering from megalomania
and that's why it's so weird to go and
attack someone that you need on your
side when he said something really quite
uncontroversial and the truth is Trump
is just as guilty of failing to aid in
the repeal of the Affordable Care Act as
Mitch McConnell they were all promising
impossible things sure Trump can sort of
hide under this idea that he's not a
career politician and he might not be
the most savvy at knowing how this works
but he's got the ideas after all but
he's just as guilty of promising
impossible things you know for us on the
Left it's nice because we can sit back
and watch this go down you know we don't
really have a stake in it either way but
I'd have to side with Trump here because
everyone in Congress knew that Trump
wasn't a policy wonk and he wasn't going
to be
controlling different members of
Congress and trying to get any sort of
bill through that was more the job of
Congress I think especially having
talked about it for seven years they've
all failed I don't think that there's a
defensive Trump for me here but they
have all completely failed and the other
sort of odd thing is I don't know if
you've noticed this Pat all of the
breaks that Donald Trump has taken from
the 17-day golf vacation that were in
the middle of has been to talk about
things where his position could be
hugely damaging to endless numbers of
people in other words he took a break
from golf to threaten North Korea with
fire and fury like we've never seen
before which presumably could lead to
people dying he came out to slam Mitch
McConnell for not repealing Obamacare
already which would have caused tens of
millions of people to end up without
health insurance and by most estimates
tens of thousands of people would have
died from lack of health care the big
picture is that this is a silly fight
for Trump to pick if there's another one
of these if this ends up being another
off-the-cuff comment it's sort of
short-sighted if slamming McConnell is
part of some broader strategy I'd be
pretty curious to hear what that
strategy is but I do hope the infighting
continues because it's good for a few
reasons number one divided Republicans
will get less less less disastrous
legislation passed the Obamacare repeal
and replace is a good example of that
number two if you have more Republicans
not feeling loyalty to Trump they are
more likely to work with Democrats on
some more reasonable bits of legislation
and number three if Republicans are not
feeling particularly loyal to Trump
because he's slamming their leaders
those Republicans are less likely to
prevent or maybe they would even help
with the removal of Trump from office
depending on what the outcome is of the
Trump Russia investigation we'll just
take a look at what the Republican
agenda right now is are they going to go
after healthcare again probably not an
unreal endless defeats maybe tax reform
but I think you need 60 votes for that
which would be a lot harder for them to
do than just getting the 51 to repeal
the Affordable Care Act so maybe Trump
will go after infrastructure next and
that's something that he can appeal to
Democrats for yeah although again he
wants to do infrastructure but in a way
that's basically crony capitalist
handouts to his buddies so yeah
conceptually Democrats might be more on
board
isolate himself from the Republicans
that's true that that also could happen
so hey continue the infighting Donny boy
I love it the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad